Willkommen im Podcast UFO, Lachen und Lernen, Geschichten, Humor, Mikrofone gerne zücken.
Gemeinsam durch Raum und Zeit, Gedanken entfalten, im Äther der Unterhaltung, wir Wissen gestalten.
Ja, hallo, vielen Dank für diese Einleitung, danke schön, so kommt man gut rein in die Folge, die da bestückt ist, reichlich, mit Stefan Tietze. Mit Florian Steffi. Richtig, mit Lernen, Lachen und Spaß, mit Florian Steffi. Zückt gerne eure Mikrofone und man muss das ein bisschen aufteilen, Markus hat hier mal die neueste Technik angeworfen und eine künstliche Intelligenz befragt, wie denn ein Intro aussehen könnte und aktuell, ja, oberes Drittel, würde ich sagen, was unsere normalen Intros angeht. Aber es klingt, als würde die AI dann denken, wir wären eine Kindersendung. Ein bisschen, ja. Finde ich eins besser als Verschwörungstheorie-Ufo-Podcast. Auch gut, aber du meinst, dass denn die Zuhörer Kinder dann alle selber das Mikrofon zücken und mitpodcasten quasi.
Ja, klingt anstrengend.
Es ist ja oft so, dass Kinder dann involviert werden, so macht mit oder zeigt auf dem Fernseher und so und beim Podcast dann, jetzt holt euer Podcast-Mikrofon raus und vielleicht denken die dann, dass sie selber podcasten, so wie der kleine Bruder, der super smart Nintendo spielt. Ich habe eine sehr frühkindliche Erinnerung, wie ich, das war mit so das erste Mal, wo mich meine Eltern alleine irgendwo gelassen haben, nicht bei Verwandten oder so, sondern mit einem Haufen fremder, fremder, und zwar war das so eine, so eine Aufführung im Urlaub, da war in dem Kulturhaus, war da so eine Aufführung für Kinder, der kleine Prinz oder sowas. Und dann war das Publikum bestückt mit einer Horde Kinder. Und alle sassen so auf ihren Sitzsäcken, so Sitzkissen. Und ich auch. Und dann war für mich ein neues Phänomen, dass man dann halt da sitzt, zuhört und dann gingen die Türen alle zu. Gleichzeitig. Genau, weil dann die Vorstellung begann und alle Türen gingen zu und ich habe nur während der Aufführung gemerkt, ich muss so dringend aufs Klo, ich weiss nicht, was ich machen soll. Und für mich waren die Türen halt zu, zu. Die sahen halt, also ich habe dann aufzustehen und bis heute verstehe ich diesen kleinen Stefan, weil ich denke, man will dann auch nicht rausgehen und dann sorry, sorry, sorry. Diese schweren Eisenportale, die dann zugeheimert werden einfach.
Man will nicht derjenige sein, der dann diese Tür aufsperrt inmitten von dieser tollen Kunstvorstellung. Also habe ich auf das Sitzkissen gepinkelt. Na vor allem bei diesen interaktiven Sachen ist es ja so, dass dann ich Ängste hätte, dass die Puppen auf mich reagieren. Wo willst du hin? Aber kannst du dich noch daran erinnern, wie du das gemacht hast? Also war das so ein, oh, ich kann es nicht mehr halten, oder war es ein, okay, jetzt mache ich es. Drei, zwei, eins, let's go. Ausweglos, ausweglos, ah. Und ich glaube, ich war während des Pinkeln-Vorgangs schon wieder beim Stück gedanklich. Ah, okay, super, ja, perfekt, das hatte ich wieder reingeholt, wie eine Werbeunterbrechung, ja, ja. Es war eher so ein, was soll ich machen, was soll ich machen, ja, jetzt, okay, jetzt ist es passiert, ich gucke weiter, und dann wieder gelacht. Und dann zum Problem wurde es dann halt, als die Lichter anging, meine Eltern mich abgeholt haben und meine ganze helle Hose dunkel war. Und das ist so, ich stelle mir vor, weil, aber ich meine es ist ein Kind, also man hat wahrscheinlich pinke, man hat auch nicht so wahnsinnig viel, aber die Vorstellung, dass da Sitzkissen an Sitzkissen sind mit Kindern und plötzlich, es ist so widerlich. Die Sitzkissen bis heute auch nicht gewaschen wurde, wenn wir mal ehrlich sind. Nein, nein. Und irgendwer sammelt dir ein, irgendein Erwachsener oder so ein Studi sammelt dir dann ein, ist eins nass. Vielleicht der kleine Prinz selbst. Ah, das ist die Moral. Wenn die Show vorbei ist und er im Backstage sitzt und sagt, jetzt muss ich wieder diese ganzen Pisskissen aufsammeln, jetzt hatte ich eine halbe Stunde Ruhm, die Kinder haben für mich geklatscht. Jeden Abend das Happy End auf der Bühne, aber hinter der Bühne gibt es kein Happy End. Hinter der Bühne werden Sitzkissen aufgesammelt, kleiner Prinz, und jetzt raus, raus mit dir, geh ins echte Leben, runter von der Bühne ins echte Leben und sammelt deine Pisskissen auf. Okay?
Schauspieler, werdet noch heute Schauspieler, studiert an der Hamburg Media School. Oder an der Akademie für Filmschauspiel, die hier direkt in der Nähe ist, wo ich ab und zu vorbeigehe und es ist jedes Mal für mich ein Mysterium, was da drin geschieht. Weil es ist ja kein Geheimnis, ich wollte mich auch mal an der Schauspielschule bewerben, das heisst, ich blicke natürlich voller Neid, grün vor Neid, natürlich auf die ganzen Studentinnen und Studenten, die dort meinen Traum leben. Oh, ich glaube, da hättest du studieren können. Und ich quasi da am Schaufenster vorbeikomme, das Schaufenster, das nur installiert wurde, damit die Leute sagen, ah, guck mal, was wir machen, wir sind besser als du. Und das Faszinierende für mich an dieser Internationalen Akademie für Filmschauspiel ist, dass die nie Schauspielern, sondern die sitzen im Stuhlkreis vor dem Dozenten. Ach, du kannst da so reingucken. Und lassen sich Sachen erklären. Ja, das ist wie so eine Fahrschule. Ja, ich wollte gerade sagen. Kennst du diese Fahrschule, wo man reinschaut? Ja, exakt. Wo man sagt, die Welt muss sehen, was hier passiert. Oder es gab zu viele sexuelle Übergriffe und die haben gesagt, wir brauchen eine gewisse Art von Überwachung. Anderes Thema, wo man dann sagt, okay, man kann da einfach reingucken. Und jedes Mal sitzt da ein Dozent und alle sitzen still da und gucken zu. Und ich frage mich wirklich, wie dieser Schauspiel-Träger abläuft. Du weißt nicht, okay. Wir muten die Laptops. Mal gucken, ob jemand seine Bingo-Karte abgeschrieben hat, Mail noch vor fünf Minuten. Aber vielleicht finden nur da, um diese Schule mal in Schutz zu nehmen, dass da nicht nur Frontalunterricht gegeben wird, vielleicht sind da nur die Kurse, die so funktionieren im Schaufenster. Kann auch sein, ja. Und der Rest ist irgendwie im, weiß nicht, in der Aula nebenan oder oben drüber. Aber ich würde da so gerne mal mich dazusetzen und dann so, was ist, wie sieht schauspielerischer Frontalunterricht aus? So, heute reden wir über Wut. Was macht Wut mit dem Körper, was ist Wut für eine Emotion? Ja, Erika? Welche Seite im Buch ist das? In unserem Buch Schauspieler? Das ist Seite 278, das Diagramm oben, Wut. Ah ja, ah darum. Wut ist eine Emotion, müsst ihr euch vorstellen, das ist so ein, naja, es ist eine gewisse Unausgeglichenheit, es ist so ein gewissen, ja Erika nochmal? Spielen wir auch mal irgendwann selbst, weil bislang, ist das eine weirde Frage, weil ich bin ja hergekommen, um Schauspielerin zu werden. Ah, Erika, Erika. Weil sie haben auch noch nicht gespielt, sie sind. Um Schauspieler, das Schauspiel zu begreifen, muss es immer erst hier oben losgehen. Der Schauspieler, der nicht versteht, kann nicht spielen. Okay, wir seit drei Jahren gucken wir dieses Buch durch und die sind viel Diagramme drin und Exzettabellen. Ja und nein, also viel über Emotionen auf so einer psychologischen Ebene, aber ich würde gerne mal spielen, ich würde da rausgehen, ich würde die Massen begeistern. Ich sehe, dass ihr mich immer noch nicht respektiert.
Vielleicht muss ich euch nochmal die Schoko-Crossi-Werbung zeigen, in der ich in den Achtzigern mitgespielt habe.
Bitte nicht.
Rainer, hol die Kassette.
Ja, Sir, hol die Kassette, es ist soweit.
Rein das Ding.
Grosse Kassette. Stimme-Crossies. Ist auch eine Art von Schauspielerei. Ich weiß ja nicht, wo meine Karriereweg mich noch hinführt, deswegen möchte ich das jetzt gar nicht. Also nur, falls jemand... Also Werbung ist für dich ein No-Go. Nein, nein, überhaupt nicht. Falls jemand zuhört. Das gute bezahlte Feld der Werbung ist für dich ein absolutes No-Go, hast du gerade ja gesagt.
Er schreibt das nochmal auf deine Website. Viel Geld für wenig Arbeit, Berufsfeld ist für mich eine absolute Ruine. Nein, überhaupt nicht. Ich gehe da gerne rein, absolut. Ah, okay, doch, du willst Geld. Richtig, man hat mir früh schon gesagt, du wirst eines Tages Werbung für Oreos machen. Und ich habe das damals als Beleidigung empfunden, weil ich übergewichtig war.
Heute sehe ich es als einen unerreichbaren Traum.
Gibt es den Oreo-Jungen, wie es den Zibak-Jungen gibt, diesen Brand-Zibak-Jungen? Noch nicht, noch nicht. Ich könnte der Oreo-Junge sein.
In meiner Grundschule war der MB-Junge in meiner Klasse.
Ah, der vor dem Gong.
Der vor dem Gong. Und zwar, ja, der war bei dir in der Schule?
Ja, in meiner Grundschule. Und das war lustig, weil da gab es dann bei unserem Toys R Us auch halt dieses MB-Jungen-Casting. Die haben, glaube ich, in verschiedenen Filialen in Deutschland, diese Toys R Us-Filialen, haben die dieses Casting gemacht, was daraus bestand, dass kleine Jungs, ich weiß nicht, ob auch Frauen dabei waren, aber halt diesen Gong-Ding in die Hand bekommen haben, diesen Schlegel,
und sich dann umdrehen musste, diesen Gong hauen. Schreckliches Casting für alle erwachsenen Beteiligten, kann ich mir vorstellen.
Und für die Caster, die alle zehn Sekunden Gong hören müssen.
Und für diesen Tonmann, der da die ganze Zeit steht.
Vielleicht kommt wieder...
Und danach alles...
Dieser riesen MB-Gong und dahinter dann irgendwie die Anzugträger, die Suits. Ja, genau. Die White Colors des MB-Imperiums. Oder die sitzen vor so einem verspiegelten Fenster, wo man nicht durchgucken kann, aber die sehen alles von da an. Herr M.? Völlig unbrauchbar. Herr M.? Herr B.? Haben wir schon unseren Jungen gefunden? Nein, nichts. Carmen ist voller Nieten. Niemand hier kann den Schlägel schlägeln, so wie es geschlägelt werden muss. Nächster. Okay. Wen haben wir hier? Stefan. Hi, ich bin Stefan. Na, dann. Ich bin sieben Jahre alt und ich bewerbe mich hiermit als MB-Jungen. Meine Hobbys sind Fussballspielen, Pokémon-Karten und Ultimate Frisbee. Hobbys sind auch völlig egal. Stefan, hattest du schon mal einen Gong-Klöppel in der Hand?? Ich hoffe, ist mir noch völlig egal.
Stefan, hattest du schon mal einen Gong-Klöppel in der Hand?
Ähm, nein, Sir, bislang noch nie.
Na dann wollen wir mal. So schwer ist das nicht.
Greif dir den Klöppel, schau in die Kamera, hau auf den Gong und dann schau nochmal in die Kamera.
Kamera, Gong, Kamera.
Ja, schlimm, schnell, ich glaub, der könnte was werden.
MB-Spiele. You better play them. Nächster! Und das war genau so, liegt das ab? Zwei Wochen, liegt das so ab, bis alle Kinder durchgekastet wurden. MB-Games. Wahnsinn. Zindergames. It's in the Gong. It's in the Gong. Und dann wurde er genommen aus ganz Deutschland. Wahnsinn. Fragezeichen, in Klammern Fragezeichen. Ich weiß nicht, ob die nicht nur vielleicht einfach in Kam waren und es sind drei Leute hingegangen. Aber ich habe es damals als grosse Begeisterung empfunden. Und dann weiß ich noch, er kam dann Montagsmorgens dann in die Schule und war halt der fucking Held. Das ist so krass, ey. Problem, in der Grundschule ist es scheißegal, da Held zu sein, mal. Es ist cool, mal der Held zu sein, aber es ist zu früh. Man piekt zu früh. Der MB-Typ, auch wie das Nirwana-Kind, klar, du bist eineinhalb Jahre alt, die ganze Welt kennt dich, aber was hast du davon? Wenn du 18 bist, niemand weiss, dass du das Nirwana-Kind warst. Genau. Ja, und er, ich weiß nicht, ob es immer noch gezeigt wird, oder ob es immer noch eine Rolle spielt, dieser Gong, aber man kennt ihn noch, und ich glaube, es war damals so diese Togo-Super-RTL-Zeit, wo man den oft gesehen hat. Das war, glaube ich, eine Werbung über MB, das ist irgendwie so eine Spielzeugfirma, glaube ich. Ja, die machen so wie Ravensburger Spiele. Genau, okay, und dann gibt es immer den Gong. Ja. Geile Idee eigentlich, ne? Coole Idee. Kinder lieben Gongs. Und dann war er dann am Schulhof und hat dann sehr viel erzählt von dem Dreh und von der Maskenbildnerin und blablabla.
Und ich wusste noch genau, wie ich diese Welt faszinierend fand und dachte, ach, Maskenbildner, natürlich, es ist alles eine grosse Illusion und eine grosse Industrie und es ist durchprofessionalisiert und toll. Und da bin ich einfach sehr froh und stolz, den zu kennen. Krass. Ich weiß nicht, was er heute macht. Und es ist auch kein echter Gong. Ich habe da nur so einen Stock in der Hand und haue da gegen so ein Tuch und dann fügen die das eine. Der ganz interessante Was? Ganz interessante Funfake. Warum rauchst du? Ja, weil es in der Branche, da schaut man sich das eine oder andere ab. Du bist sieben Jahre alt, deine Lungen explodieren sofort, wenn du rein mit die Erdemotionen schießt. Pass auf, kleine Randnotiz noch für euch, die ihr gerade so gierig lauscht. Das Geräusch, das man hört, den tatsächlichen Gong. Wie gesagt, du musst nicht rauchen, wir finden dich auch so cool, weil du da in der Werbung bist. Den Gong, den man hört in dem Clip, das war nicht mein Gong. Ich habe da draufgehauen, aber das war kein richtiger Gong. Und dann der Regisseur, wie hieß er nochmal? Stanley Kubrick. Stanley Kubrick. Kubrick. Kubrick meinte dann, der Take war's, aber wir brauchen einen Gong. Und dann kam nochmal jemand anders rein und hat gegongt. Der hat nur gegongt. Professioneller Gonger, Tam-Tam-Spieler. Genau wie bei meinem ersten Schauspiel, bei meinem ersten Gig, war es ja so, dass ich Hirte war im Krippenspiel, ganz klassisch. Das Krippenspiel ist wirklich die deutsche Heranführung an den Schauspielerberuf und Abwendung in einem, weil man danach auch eigentlich keinen Bock mehr hat auf sowas, oder? Es ist eine Talenteschmiede. Ja. Es ist eine Talenteschmiede, wo wirklich, wo man geschlagen wird. Könnte man auch einen guten Sketch machen. Ja. So die ganzen Darsteller vom Krippenspiel mit so Talking Heads, die dann seit zehn, ja, als ich die Rolle vom Schaf drei bekommen habe, fand ich für mich einen Durchbruch. Aber die Rollenarbeit war intensiv, das war schon hart, also das ist, glaube ich, die grösste Rolle, mein Sprecher, sechsjährige Kinder, also.
Der sechsjährige Tim war nämlich Method unterwegs, er war in seiner Klasse, hier sehen wir ihn in seiner Klasse, sechs Monate lang schlüpfte er in die Rolle des Schafs und dann sieht man so die Lehrerin im Talking Head, ja, es war nicht einfach, also er hat dann wirklich dieses Schaf verkörpert die ganze Zeit und er hat es nicht sein lassen und dann habe ich da Tim und auch die Eltern eingeladen, wir hatten eine Klassenkonferenz, eine Schulkonferenz, aber irgendwie dieser Kurs dieses Jahr hat es mit dem Krippenspiel irgendwie ernst gemeint. Würden Sie rückblickend sagen, das war es wert, als Sie dann die Aufführung gesehen haben? Nein, nein, kein Mikrofon hat funktioniert, nie, alle haben den Text trotzdem vergessen. Timmy war sehr überzeugend in der Rolle des Schafs und ist die Frage, was leistet das Schaf im Gesamtkontext dieser ja doch immer sehr gleichen Geschichte? Ich bin gestresst, wir sind überfordert, es gibt kaum Lehrer mehr, es macht keinen Spaß. Zurück zu Timmy, ja gut, das Schaf war natürlich eine essentielle Rolle. Also das Schaf simulisiert natürlich durchs Weisse noch Fell erstmal die Unschuld, ja, Marias Unschuld. Und also ich bin da auch mit unserem Regisseur Wolfgang da ganz intensiv in die Rollenarbeit gegangen, auf jeden Fall. Wolfgang, also ein kleiner Junge, der so einen Schal hat, der bis auf den Boden ragt und dann wirft er den so um sich herum, braucht es beide Hände dafür. Ja. Also für eine klassische Interpretation, da hätten mich wirklich sieben Ziegen ziehen müssen. Also nur über meine Leiche hätte es eine klassische Inszenierung wie letztes Jahr geben können von Petra. Nein, postmodern muss es sein. Die Geschichte muss neu interpretiert und neu erzählt werden. Und der Cast war wunderbar. Das sage ich Ihnen, wie es ist. Bei der Generalprobe kam es zu einem Zwischenfall. Josef Mark Acht beschwerte sich über die Zustände des Probens. Ich höre nichts. Leute, hinten da reden. Reden hinten, über die Lampen. Ich kann mich nicht konzentrieren. Wolfgang, verstehst du das nicht? Ich kann mich hier vorne nicht konzentrieren. Mark, ich weiss, die Situationen sind schwierig. Aber du musst alles geben, morgen ist die Aufführung. Wolfgang, ich bin ein Schauspieler. Marc, ich weiss es doch, ich leid doch genauso unter den Bedingungen. Ich bin Joseph. Ich leid doch genauso. Ich stehe mit meinem Bild für dieses Krippenspiel. Ich bin Joseph. Nutz das, nutze es, bieden! Nutz die Wut, die Wut auf Gott! Ich mach' einen Wirbel in Amerika! Ja, das war die acht, achte Klasse. Und die Eltern mussten sich acht von diesen Aufführungen hintereinander anschauen. Die gesamte Schule einfach. Es wäre aber auch mal lustig, so ein Arzi-Krippenspiel. Ich weiß, die Weihnachtsfolge aus Kirche. Ja, ja. Aber so ein Arzi-Krippenspiel.
Finde ich richtig gut.
Finde ich richtig gut. Volkszählung.
Mäh, mäh, mäh, mäh, Konsum, Konsum, Konsum, mäh, mäh, mäh.
Die Annäherung des Todes, ein Engel erscheint, Frauke Petri, steigt vom Himmel die Ankündigung. Ich war rein und zart, die Jungfrau, doch Gott, er stach, er stach tief. Konsum, Konsum, Konsum, Konsum. Maria spreizt die Beine, lasziv wälzt sie sich über den Schlamm, der auf der Bühne ausgelegt wurde. Nein heißt nein! Ein Gott kennt kein Nein. Trauma, Trauma, Trauma, Generation Trauma! Fuck, die Eltern sind schon... Es war wirkmächtig, aber... Wer hat jetzt gew? Ich habe es nicht ganz verstanden. Aber okay, interessant, dass Frau Kepeti aufgedaucht ist.
Als Engel, was ist das für ein Paginbocha?
Ich meine, was ist das für ein Kämie, was ist, naja, da wird der deutsche LK noch lange dran zu knabbern haben.
Gott hat gesagt, es gibt kein Nein, habe ich jetzt richtig verstanden?
Ja, ich weiß auch nicht genau. Warum hat der Pfarrer das zugelassen, dass das passiert? Ach, ich habe da schon ein bisschen Bock drauf. Eigentlich würde ich das gerne mal wieder sehen. Ja, eigentlich möchte ich auch jedes Jahr nur aus dem Grund meiner Familie Weihnachten in die Kirche, weil ich das Krippenspiel sehen will. Ach geil. Vielleicht schaue ich mir das dieses Jahr mal auf YouTube an, irgendwie so. Weil es gibt tatsächlich auch Schulen, die es sehr ernst nehmen. Ich habe ein YouTube-Video gesehen von so einem Weihnachtskonzert, wo eine Schule es einfach viel zu ernst genommen hat, wo der Chor auch ultra professionell war, mit Inszenierung, Choreografie, in der Aula wirklich schwarz verkleidet, mit Lichtinszenierung und so. Pyro. Pyro, wirklich alles drin und dann die die verschiedenen Klassen und es war einfach richtig krass.
Der Engel scheint mit dem Stroboskoplicht und alle so, oh da, Laser ins Publikum.
Ja, das war schon richtig krass. Also da gibt es auch welche, die da, sage ich mal, diesen amerikanischen Musical, High School Musical Ansatz haben, zu sagen, wir machen das richtig.
Das wäre so fucking amazing, wenn dann so ein geiler Soundteppich kommt, so ein Synthi, wenn dann der Engel erscheint, um die frohe Kunde zu verkunden.
Und dann kommt so ein ... Und dann kommt so ein ...
Ist schon sehr gehast worden in der Kirche mit Beirauch und so.
Und dann kommt so ein Laserteppich.
Und dann sieht man oben so den kleinen Timmy im Engelskostüm, kommt von der Decke runter.
Panik in seinen Augen. Er Panik weint, weil er schon sehr lange, weil die haben es geprobt, aber nur in der praktischen Aufführung hängt er schon seit zwei Stunden da oben.
Er muss dringend aufs Klo und er fliegt über die gesamte Publikum. Alle Eltern sitzen da und er kann es nicht mehr halten. Die Lautsprecher sind auf tausend gestellt, das Laser strahlt allen in die Augen, man sieht sein Weinen, aber man hört es nicht. Und er kommt runter und dann hat er natürlich trotzdem, kriegt er dann dieses klappernde Mikrofon in die Hand gedrückt, was überbringe die fröhliche Botschaft. Oh, die Glocken! Sorry Gott, sorry Gott, das war zu viel, was für mich auf einmal, was ihr immer nicht hört. Ja, was ihr immer nicht hört. Gerade leuchten die Glotten. Die Glotten.
Gerade läuten die Glocken.
Das ist genau der Blackout wie beim MB-Jungen-Casting.
Genau alles kommt wieder hoch. Es war genau wie damals, als ich den Schlägel falsch rumgehalten habe.
Ich dachte, man hält ihn an diesem weichen Stoff. Ich dachte, man hält ihn da unten fest.
Woher soll ich das denn wissen?
Um ein lautes Geräusch zu erzeugen. Seit wann benutzt man das Weiche? Das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn. Das macht keinen Sinn. Nee, was ich eigentlich sagen wollte, war Ja, die IAF findest du bescheuert. Nee, dass ich damals beim Krippenspiel, weil du gesagt hast, es gibt dann noch den echten Jungen, den Musiker, der noch mal auf den Gong haut. So ähnlich war es bei mir auch. Und zwar habe ich einen Hirten gespielt, der sollte Flöte spielen, aber ich konnte keine Flöte spielen. Also wurde aus dem Off die richtige Flöte eingespielt. Also hat sich tatsächlich die beste Flötenspielerin der Klasse, auch ein Kind, hinterm Vorhang versteckt und hat Flöten gespielt. Aber anders als alle anderen Kindern, ohne jegliche schauspielerische Talente. Genau. Nein, wie Bullshit, lass sie doch einfach dann diese Rolle spielen. Was ich mir im Nachhinein auch oft gefragt habe,
warum nicht, aber man hat gesagt, nee, du spielst
das, du tust so, hat natürlich jetzt nicht
von der Synchronität her mega geklappt.
Und ich habe es auch klassisch übertrieben,
wenn jemand sagt, tu mal so auf einer Tastatur
tippen, dann ist man ultra
hektisch und tippt. Tu mal so, als ob du wartet.
Hm.
Das finde ich immer so lustig. Man muss wahnsinnig viel tun, plötzlich. Herzrasen kriege ich, wenn ich das sehe, weil das aussieht wie jemand, der so nervös ist. Ja, ja. Das ist auch super. Und ja, interessanterweise habe ich es dann einfach übertrieben. Und ich habe wirklich die Flöte gespielt, als wäre sie heiß, glaube ich. Als wäre sie in dem Moment einfach richtig heiß geworden und ich habe mit einem Fingern so schnelles Skilt und währenddessen und ich einfach, als bin ich gerade irgendwie so ein Paganino. Fast. Ja, fast. Ein Buchstabe. Ich war der Nachthimmel. Du warst der Nachthimmel? Ja. Sie waren das? Ich war der Nachthimmel. Das war eine der besten Performances des Nachthimmels, die ich je gesehen habe. Es gibt so ein … Ich habe zwei Schilder in der Hand, beide sind der Nachthimmel. Man hat mir nicht mal den Tag gegeben und die Nacht, sondern beide Schilder, die ich hatte, waren der Nachthimmel. Und es gibt ein Bild, wie ich gespannt stehe, so mit ganz aufgerissenen Augen, beide Schilder in der Hand, starre den whatever an, anleitenden, ja, den Dirigenten, Dirigenten, und dann gibt es ein Bild, wie ich die hochhalte und grinse. Und vielleicht kann ich es rausfinden, wenn wir jetzt auch visuelle Medien, vielleicht kann ich es euch zeigen. Aber es gibt auf jeden Fall Bilder von mir. Da waren dann Sterne drauf. Da waren Sterne drauf und auch eine Sternschnuppe und vielleicht sogar der Nachtstern. Dieser, dem sie gefolgt sind, bis sie dann an der Krippe angekommen sind. Eine wacke Geschichte auch, ehrlich gesagt. Ich glaube auch gar nicht so leicht, einem Stern zu folgen. Also mach das mal. Das ist einfach so, aber welchen Weg nimmt man jetzt und wie und dann ... Vor allem strenger um geht man nicht im Kreis, weil der Stern dreht sich ja, der Nachthimmel. Nicht im Kreis, aber so ein ... Ich glaube, du rennst halt in wahnsinnig viele Sackgassen rein, weil die Heiligen drei Könige, die haben zwar die Richtung, aber die haben ja keinen Weg. Das heisst, sie gehen einfach in den Weg und sind einfach in absolute Sackgassen und sagen, ja, jetzt müssen wir wieder rumdrehen und müssen wieder zurück und dann mit anderen. Ja, müssen wir wieder da rumdrehen. Na, ich habe doch gesagt, dass du auf den anderen Weg gehen sollst. Ach, na, nicht den anderen Weg. Ich habe dir gesagt, Balthasar, ich habe dir gesagt, dass wir denge, Mellichior, hörst nicht zu.
Du hörst nicht zu, du bist der schlechteste Be Ich dachte auch, vielleicht sind sie zu acht gestartet. Ja, okay, kann auch sein, drei Alligator gefressen oder was? Nö, aber einer ist verhungert, der eine musste gegessen werden von den anderen, damit die überhaupt den Weg noch schaffen. Ja, ja. Sowas.
Der eine sass zu lange auf so einem Sitzkissen und wurde krank und dachte dann, okay, ich leg mich hier hin zum Sterben einfach. Vor allem hatten die auch gar keinen Gefolge oder irgendwie sowas, Leute, die mitlaufen, sondern der König sagt, so Freunde, eine Ansage, hallo, hallo, mal alle, Hofstart, mal alle. äh, folgendes folgendes, eine Sache
ich habe am Horizont einen Stern gesehen
und ich werde es packen, also ich gehe, ich gehe jetzt und ich gehe zum Heiland und wir brauchen König, ja, ich bin erstmal raus, also ich packe es, ich habe einen Rucksack und ich gehe alleine und ja.
Ja, mein Name ist Griebelbach vom Augsburger Stadtanzeiger. Vielen Dank für das Einrufen der Pressekonferenz. Hat er nicht umgebracht. Ich dachte, wir hätten die Presse umgebracht. Euer Majestät, eine Frage, um es richtig zu verstehen, Sie geben hier alles auf. Nein, nö. Den Status, ihren Hof, alles nur um diesem komischen hell erleuchtenden Stern am Himmel zu folgen, um den Sohn Gottes zu ... Nö, nee, nee, ich geb's nicht auf, ich bin halt nur weg. Also ich pack's halt, ich geh erst mal ... Ja, aber Ihre Reise dauert zehn Jahre hin, zehn Jahre zurück, wenn es gut läuft, ja. Dann werden Sie nicht mehr am Leben sein. Also so, nur um es richtig zu verstehen, ohne Gefolge ... Will hier jemand geköpft werden gerade? Entschuldigung. Okay, dann machst du es mir aber auch leicht. Komm, okay, weg mit ihm. Peinlicher Schrei wäre das. Ja, wenn das sein letzter Schrei wäre. Man muss nicht schreien, so beim Henker. Eine Frage. Sie nehmen die Axt. Habe ich das richtig verstanden. Sie nehmen die Axt und dann, ich lege auf dem Schafott und dann so, und dann, wann soll ich schreien? Also wann ist der letzte Moment, wo ich noch schreien kann? Wann können Sie noch schreien? Also der letzte Moment ist statistisch gesehen, die meisten halten sich ehrlich gesagt zurück. Ah, okay. Weil der Schmerz, der ist nicht spürbar, weil der Schmerz equals Tod. Okay, okay. Jetzt ist es so, ich würde gerne schreien. Also gibt es eine Möglichkeit, gibt es da einen Rahmen? Ja, wir haben hier dieses Buch und da können Sie sich jetzt ein paar Inspirationen rausholen. Also zum Beispiel den langen Schrei, es gibt den kurzen Schrei, es gibt den erstickenden Schrei. Hier gibt es den Komfort Plus Set. Genau, den Komfort Plus, da würden wir Ihnen extra einem zwölfköpfringen, wie man ganz, wie man cool schreit um ein cooles ... Ich glaube, das nehme ich, ja. Ich würde gerne schreien. Ich glaube, es ist einfach gut auch für die Umwelt, also das Umfeld. So, ich bin ein bisschen nervös, ich wurde noch nie geköpft, tut mir aber kein Problem. Das ist das Erste, Sie machen das häufiger, aber es ist, ja. Nee, gut, dann machen wir das so wunderbar. Sollen wir noch ein Outfit beraten? Ach, ich habe jetzt einen schwarzen Leinsack an, ne? Also das ist jetzt natürlich ... Ja, das trägt man gerade. Ja, das ist die Mode gerade. Ja, was soll ich machen? Wir tragen alle quasi dasselbe. Ich meine, früher hatten wir noch andere Sachen. Früher hatten wir so Baggy Jeans und so. Ja, ja, ja. Aber klar, was die Jugend von heute so trägt. Was haben Sie denn gemacht? Ich war Reporter, Journalist tatsächlich. Ah, Anzeiger. Ich habe eine Frage zu, nein, es war gar nicht interessant, am Ende war es gar nicht die Frage, sondern eher die reine Faktenbeobachtung, dass der König ja nach einigen Jahren tot sein wird, aber das ist dann anscheinend schon zu viel. Ja, genau, na gut, in dem Sinne, schön Tod, schöne Reise, schöne letzte Reise. Danke, ja wunderbar. Ciao.
Tschüss.
Musst er dann was bezahlen? Wahrscheinlich schon.
Er hat auch nicht mehr von seinem Geld.
Tatsächlich, Henker im Mittelalter ist ein krasses Thema, weil die auch eine Ultra-Sonderstellung hatten, die lebten ganz alleine und teilweise war das auch so, waren die wirklich so wie, ja wie so Dämonen fast so, wo dann hieß, wenn du die anfasst oder wenn du die zu lange anschaust, kommst du direkt in die Hölle und niemand darf sich denen nähern und irgendwie so. Da habe ich mal so eine Doku gesehen, so ultra strange Berichte, weil man wirklich auf den so, weil der ist eh hinüber, der hat eh schon ganz viele Leben auf dem Gewissen und der lebt auch so ein Extraleben, wird extra gut bezahlt auch, aber darf irgendwie, der woh fluss irgendwie ganz strange schaut euch das gerne mal an macht da mal ein deep dive wochenende spannend lohnt sich glaube ich da mal wirklich tief rein zu gehen in die in diese geschichte habe ich mal gesehen das ist ein cleveres rhetorisches mittel um leute auf seine seite zu holen oder auf ihre ist es zu nicken während man spricht also wenn man einen Also, wenn man einen Punkt macht, von dem man will, dass andere den annehmen. Ach, während du selber sprichst, nickst du? Genau, weil man neigt ja beim Sprechen immer auch zum Spiegeln des Gegenüber. Wenn man schon einen Punkt macht, der einer Überzeugung bedarf, dann nickt doch ein bisschen, dann ist der gegenüber geneigt zu sagen, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, ich folge dir überall hin. Ja, ich will dich, willst du mich heiraten?
Nein.
Ach so, äh, was macht mein Kopf?
Zählt das schon?
Ja, japp, japp, du bist jetzt schon rechtlich mit mir verheiratet.
Japp, ich will.
Ich habe ein, äh.
Manipuliert eure Partner und Partnerinnen doch einfach zu einer Hochzeit.
Genau.
Zum Beispiel.
Wunderbar, wenn sie es nötig haben.
Ja. Ich habe ein Deep Drive-Wochenende gemacht, und zwar in die wunderbare Welt von Atlantropa. Habe ich mich mal reingeguckt, weil Mittelmeer ist ja ein Begriff. Ja, war ich gerade. Strand, Balotze, schön, Venedig, Venedig, Venedig, Venedig, so und dann natürlich Sizilien, Korsika, Sardinien, Ibiza, Griechenland, herrlich.
Und dann gab es einen Architekten namens Hermann Sörgel, der das gesehen hat, Mittelmeer und sich dachte, das geht besser, das geht noch besser.
Und zwar ist ihm aufgefallen, dass das Mittelmeer riesengross ist, aber es gibt ja nur zwei winzig kleine Verbindungen. Einmal Gibraltar und dann zum Schwarzen Meer. Genau. Und dann hat er gesagt, ja, wir mauern das zu. Weil der hat sich diese Öffnungen mal angeguckt, der ist ja mal nach Gibraltar gefahren und hat gemerkt, da fließt Wasser rein ins Mittelmeer. Warum? Das ist ja ein grosses Meer. Und dann hat er lange nachgedacht und hat verstanden, im Mittelmeer verdunstet mehr Wasser als aussen, also fließt Wasser rein. Und er hat gesagt, wenn wir da jetzt einen Damm bauen, dann sinkt der Meeresspiegel um 100 Meter im gesamten Mittelmeer. Und er wollte diesen Bereich dann nutzen für neue Fläche? Genau, das war dann erstmal die Idee. So Forst-Landwirtschaft-artige Fragen? 500.000 Quadratkilometer Land sollte es neu geben. Nachteil ist halt komplett versalzen, weil da war halt jahrhundertelang mehr. Ja, aber rotes Meer, Todes Meer, gut, man hört schon am Namen. Da ist es vielleicht keine gute Idee. Aber es gibt erstmal mehr Land, was geil ist. Mehr Land ist immer geil. Ich bin Landgeil. Ich bin Landratte. Absolut, was ich mir vorstelle, wie krass das ist, weil das ist ja dann Land, wo immer schon Meer war, also da gibt's ja dann Korallen und Muscheln, also das ist so wie wenn du aus einem ausgetrockneten Meer lebst, kann man, ist das überhaupt, ich stell mir das Meer immer so wahnsinnig ungeben vor, aber vielleicht ist es das gar nicht, also vielleicht ist es auch einfach eine Fläche und dann ist es halt eine Strasse und was auch immer und Sörgel war eigentlich, der kommt ursprünglich aus der Wasserkraft. Die Idee war nämlich, wenn wir so ein riesiges. Wann war das? Das war 1932, hat er sein Buch veröffentlicht. Und woher kommt Hermann Sörgel? Hermann Sörgel kommt aus Deutschland und er kommt ursprünglich aus der Wasserkraftbranche und hat dann gesagt, wenn wir so einen riesigen Damm haben in Gibraltar, können wir Unmengen an Strom erzeugen. Er hat sogar gedacht, genug Strom für ganz Europa. Einfach mal straight, das Problem ist weg. Erstmal eine gute Aussage. Also ganz sehr falsch. Und der Staudamm hätte halt einfach riesen gross sein müssen, ich glaube so dreissig Meter, zweieinhalb Kilometer lang, dreihundert Meter hoch und es gab zu dem Zeitpunkt nicht genug Zement auf der gesamten Erde, um das zu machen, Nachteil, aber. Der Gesamte. Und was interessant war, weil ihr natürlich jetzt wahrscheinlich denkt, okay, das wurde 1932 veröffentlicht, er war Deutscher, also guckt er mal, wer hat Bock auf diese Ideen alle.
Und natürlich ist er dann zu den Nazis. denkt, okay, das wurde 1932 veröffentlicht, er war Deutscher, also
guckt er mal, wer hat Bock auf diese Ideen
alle. Und natürlich ist er dann zu den Nazis
gegangen und hat gesagt, sag mal,
ihr redet doch ständig hier von Lebensraum und so,
wie wär's denn, mega cool,
einfach hier mehr
Land. Und
dann haben die Nazis gesagt,
nee, das ist uns zu pazifistisch.
Land ja, aber wenn, dann schon mit Krieg. Das muss dann schon sein. Nein, doch. Nein. Und die haben sogar einen Propagandafilm produzieren lassen gegen Sörgel, Publikationsverbot in Deutschland, weil denen war das nicht kriegerisch genug. What? Die haben gesagt, nee, machen wir nicht. Tja, schon verrückt, ne? Das ist total weird.
Einfach zu sagen, ja, gut, Merland ist natürlich immer gut, aber wir wollen natürlich einen Krieg haben. Also das muss schon sein. Also ohne Krieg, wo ist der Spaß? Das ist ja unfassbar. Also einfach da den Dampon und dann warten, das ist doch nichts. Das kann doch nicht sein. Weil ich dachte immer, dass die alles ihre der Ideologie unterordnen, im Sinne von, der Krieg ist nur das nötige Mittel für die Drecksideologie. Turns out, nee. Nee, Krieg ist schon auch Teil der Ideologie. Das habe ich nicht gewusst. Und ja, ganz spannend, letzten Endes wurde es nicht gemacht, weil Hermann Sörgel bei einem mysteriösen Fahrradunfall ums Leben kam. Auf dem Weg zu einem Vortrag wurde er von einem Auto angefahren und ist gestorben.
Nein!
Bis heute weiss man nicht, wer der Autofahrer war.
Und wir lösen Sörgels Tod?
Wir könnten, ja vielleicht lösen wir Sörgels Tod.
Autofahrer?
Ja, wer weiß nicht, wer es ist. Es war glaube ich so in den 50er Jahren, also Hitler war es wahrscheinlich nicht, oder vielleicht doch, er hat überlebt und hat sich ein Auto geholt. Und Sörgel-Rache geschworen. Oder weil er sich denkt, das wäre eigentlich schon besser gewesen als dieser verdammter Krieg. Am Ende denkt er sich, scheiße, diese ganze Salznummer. Bei Italien war er verbündet und so, passt das? Tu mir vor, das ist ja absurd, aber das ist ja Wahnsinn. Also richtig abgefahren, wie die Nazis alle immer noch blöder werden. Ja, schon, wo du denkst, je mehr man lernt darüber, desto bescheuerter werden sie immer noch. Ja, ich habe hier eine Idee, wo es wirklich eine harte Linie braucht, wo wir mal alle dazu überzeugen oder zwingen müssen, zusammenzuarbeiten, ganz Europa.
Die Nazis sind die perfekte Stelle. Der dachte sich auch wahrscheinlich so, ich bin hier genau, das gefällt mir, alle Uniformen, die Flaggen, die ziehen das durch, die haben ein grosses Projekt. Die haben ein Gespür für die Scale, die ich auch brauche. Genau, und dann sitzt er da irgendwie vor Martin Bormann und dann sagst du so, ja, und das ist die Idee. Was halten Sie? Ja, prinzipiell cool, aber wir wollen halt einfach Leute abmurksen im Krieg.
Wie bitte?
Wir wollen Länder überfallen, Blitzkrieg und Panzer und so und wir lieben halt den kriegerischen Akt.
Genau, aber das ist dann gar nicht nötig, weil sie haben dann unendliche Salzwüsten und also mehr Land und Strom und so für all ihre Projekte. Ja, nee, wir melden uns. Oh, danke. Dann nehme ich das Diorama wieder mit. Ihr Modell. Ich baue das Diorama wieder ab. Nehmen Sie Ihr Zehn-Meter-Modell wieder mit. Das ist jetzt alles schon aufgebaut, ne? Nee, vielen Dank. Können Sie mir die Flipchart vielleicht? Wir melden uns, und fahren Sie vorsichtig. Ja, okay, mach ich. Fahren Sie immer schön vorsichtig. Immer schön nach rechts und links gucken, bevor Sie die Strasse überqueren. Mach ich. Wiedersehen. Tür geht zu. Krieg, krieg, krieg, krieg, krieg, krieg, krieg, krieg, ja, krieg, so ein Plastikpanzer. Das ist so alber. Auch was man über Hitler so noch jetzt erfährt, das ist alles so, das kommt ja eine Menge raus. Deppiger Depp-Idiot. Das ist auch, er war ja ein großer Richard-Wagner-Fan, und es gibt so eine unfertiggestellte Oper, die ist einfach nie fertig geworden, hat Wagner abgebrochen, weil er keinen Bock mehr hatte
oder es schlecht fand oder so. Und dann hat
Hitler sich überlegt, die zu Ende
zu komponieren. Ah, super. Und hat sich dann dahin
gesetzt.
Das ist unfassbar.
Aber ich mag, also man kann natürlich über den Mann
sagen, was man will, viel Kritik berechtigt,
aber den Ehrgeiz
und den Enthusiasmus und das Selbstvertrauen
zu haben, sich an so eine unvollendete Symphonie und Oper zu setzen und zu sagen, so, Tag eins, wo ist mein Bleistift? So, wollen wir mal. Das ist der Bleistift, da muss es angespitzt werden. Gut, dann mache ich da. Göbbels? Ich dachte, wir wären beim Josef gebieden. Nee, Entschuldigung, ich war jetzt zu formell. Tut mir leid. Komm mal her. Komm mal her. Adolf, hi. Komm mal her. Moin. Komm mal her. Du, hast du noch einen Spitzer für mich? Äh, selbstverständlich. Der da warst du im Propagandaministerium. Ah, was machst du da gerade? Ach ja. Schreibst du ein neues Buch oder? Nee, nee, ich will eine Oper vollenden von Wagner. Richard Wagner? Genau, ich habe schon ein paar Ideen mit Krieg und so. Du hast doch noch nie komponiert in deinem ganzen Leben und hast auch gar keinen musikalischen Background. Jede Reise beginnt mit einem Schritt. Ja, aber willst du nicht erst mal anfangen, irgendwie Noten zu lernen oder Klavierunterricht zu lernen? Ach nee, also ich meine, du hast ja selber geschrieben, Universitalgenie, historisch einmalig und so, historische Figur, das sind doch deine Worte, oder? Ja, nur ... Der Führer kann alles, hast du geschrieben. Der Führer geht vor, das Volk folgt. Also warum, oder ... Ja, genau, klar. Oder war das ... Nee, nee, klar, das stimmt schon so, aber es ist ja eher so, ab der Fakt der Figur. Ich meine, im Konkreten solltest du vielleicht ein bisschen Grundkenntnisse haben, um überhaupt irgendwie den ersten Schritt gehen zu können. Du hast alles gesagt, was ich anfasse, wird zu Gold. Alles, was ich mache, wird funktioniert. Das habe ich auch gerne gelesen. Ja, ja, klar, aber immer, wenn halt auch realistischerweise eine Grundlage dafür besteht, was dann folgt. Aber, ähm, nee, ich will auch gar nicht ... Ich habe langsam das Gefühl, du meinst das gar nicht. Nee, doch, klar, hey, hey, voll, okay. Weil natürlich habe ich Unsicherheiten. Natürlich habe ich Unsicherheiten. Weißt du noch nicht, ich weiss doch nicht genau, also ich weiss doch nicht, was ich mache, aber ich glaube, ich probiere es halt mal. Nee, ist doch voll okay. Nee, dann lasse ich es. Nee, dann schmeiss das alles weg, dann brauche ich auch keinen Stift. Genau so lang war das. Er hat sich hingesetzt, hat nicht funktioniert, weil er keine Kenntnisse hat und man denkt, was ein fucking Vollidiot, was ein fucking narzisstisches Arschloch, wissen wir alles.
Ja, aber auch ein bisschen sympathisch, finde ich.
Also ich finde schon, wenn du nichts über ihn weisst und du sagst so, so, Dienstag zehn Uhr, los geht's, Seite eins.
Opa, Opa, Opa, Opa, Opa, die, ähm, vielleicht was mit Tieren.
Oh, jetzt erst mal einen Kaffee.
Ja, jetzt erst mal, vielleicht erst mal, vielleicht höre ich mir erst mal eine an.
Oh, jetzt auch schon, jetzt auch schon elf.
Jetzt ist schon elf, ne?
Wo ist denn Eva eigentlich nochmal? Die ist bei ihren Eltern, ne? Die ist bei den Eltern, ne? Vielleicht erst mal, hm, gibt's, hab ich eine Rede? Ne. Krass, wenn man das Papierstück kräuselt und dann hinten kann man das perfekt in diesen Ring werfen. Habe ich das schaffen? Habe ich das schaffen? Ah, nee. Nee, hatte ich. Ah, jetzt bin ich getroffen. Ich hab daneben. Morgen ist schon Dienstag. Dienstag. Dienst. Diensttag, das war eine gute Idee. Wer hat sich das ausgedacht? Wer hat die Namen für die Wochentage? Ach, bestimmt war es dieser Sörgel. Ich hasse diesen Sörgel. Dieser verdammte Sörgel. Warte mal, der hat hier Vorträge. Hm. Na ja, gut, er hatte eine schlechte Idee, aber ... Ja, aber auf der anderen Seite war er schon recht frech, also das war ... Ja, ja, den ganzen Krieg umschiffst, hätte er. Ja. Guck mal. Ja, Publikationsverbot, sehr gut. Ja. Fahrradun Oh. Naja. Naja, Unfall. Diesmal schaffe ich es wieder. Papierknäuel in den Ringer. Ja, so ist es doch. So läuft das doch am Ende. Der innere Monolog Hitlers. Dialog. Fuck. Ich meine, so ein Diktator hat auch mal einen faulen Tag. Ich meine, das frage ich mich bei solchen Leuten wirklich immer, weil die ja ultra energisch und ziel und so den ganzen Tag im Bunker und den ganzen Tag über Karten und so und dann auch über committed, also da war ja auch ein Ding, dass die Generäle gesagt haben, Chima, wir machen das schon, aber nein, nein, nein, ich will überall und dann auch der auch mal wirklich einen so schlappen Tag hat und einfach so, auch habe ich irgendwie so lust auf gar nichts oder für die jogginghose nie ausziehen nee heute habe ich irgendwie keine lust today i don't feel like doing anything wird von wurde von der seite eingespielt wurde von der seite von jemandem eingespielt der flöten kann, pfeifen kann. Ach Keitel, sie heitern mich immer auf. Keitel, sie heitel. Oh Mann, Top 5 Nazis von Florentin präsentiert. Im Sinne von, also je grauenhafter, desto weiter oben. Huiuiui. Also in Nazi-Kategorien die besten Nazis. Okay. In unseren Kategorien die absolut schlimmsten, grauenvollsten Menschen. Das ist natürlich schwierig, weil das Ding ist, ich hab mir irgendwann auch mal so ein, das heisst irgendwie das schwarze Buch der Nazi-Personalien und da stehen einfach mehr oder weniger alle Nazis drin, einfach alle. So, also da stehen auch wirklich dann niedrigrangige Leute drin und einfach alle, die irgendwie so ein bisschen was hatten. Hast du mal nach deinem Nachnamen geschaut? Exakt, das wollte ich gerade sagen. Immer wenn ich jemanden kennenlerne, dann blätter ich erstmal nach. Zu Hause, machst du dein Safe auch. Ja genau, ist da nicht irgendwas, ich meine klar, kann man ja, also es ist ja nicht direkt, also hat ja nicht, also kann ja dann, aber ist natürlich schon mal was, was man in der Hinterhand hat. So, ne, also wenn du so auf ein erstes Date gehst und dann sagst du so, aha, ja, ah, Annika, ne? Ah, okay, Annika Reitleiner, interessant, interessant. Was hat deine Familie so gemacht? Also mein Vater ist Hertenrewe, hier in der Südstadt direkt, und meine Mama ist einfach Hausfrau. Und dein Opa, weisst du noch, was der so gemacht hat? Oscar Reitleitner? Wo warst du denn vorne? Achso, dachte ich jetzt einfach. Ich weiss nicht, also irgendwie, nach dem Krieg hat er dann so einen Einzelhandelsgeschäft. Ah ja, nach dem Krieg. Ich glaube, Schuster oder sowas. Okay, okay, nach dem Krieg. Also, ich finde es einfach, Geschichte ist immer super spannend. Weißt du, was er, wir haben den Krieg immer? Naja, da haben wir nie darüber gesprochen eigentlich. Aber danach, wie gesagt, Schuster und dann hat er, ich habe sogar noch einen Schuh von ihm zu Hause. Das ist eigentlich ganz lustig. Spannend. Weil es ist ja ganz spannend, weil ich habe hier nämlich einen Oscar-Reitleitner auch gefunden als... Was ist für ein Buch? Was ist für ein schwarzes, unheilvolles Buch? Genau, als hier KZ-Kommandant Treblinka. Es ist ein anderer Oscar-Reitleiner. Ach, war jetzt einfach mal nur so, aber wäre ja schade, wenn das... Egal, wollen wir noch ein Dessert? Was mache ich hier eigentlich? Ich hätte gerne Milch, Sahne, ich hätte gerne Apfelstrudel, ich hätte gerne Apfelstrudel. Ich hätte gern Milch mit Sahne. Ich hätte gern ein Glas Milch mit Sahne, bitte.
Wie kriege ich die Referenz rüber? Wie kriege ich die Referenz so zielsicher nach Hause gefahren, dass du es verstehst?
Ich hätte gern Apfelstrudel. Und du so.
Okay.
Aber ist immer gut, ist immer gut. Diese grosse Pfeife. Was sind wir gerade? In Doris Bastard sind sie sogar. Ja, ich weiss, aber okay. Ja, ich verstehe auch nicht, was sie zu ist. Aber ist es ja nicht verboten, Milch mit Sahne zu trinken? Nein, ich wollte ja nur sagen, dass sie vielleicht mit dem Boot ist. Ist Sahne einfach krasse Milch oder was ist es?
Nee, fluffige Milch. Aufgeplusterte, fluffige Milch. Jetzt mal nur eine Frage? Kondensmilch? Gesüsste Milch. Aber wo kommt Kondens rein? Also Kondensieren ist ja der Übergang von einer gasförmigen zu einer flüssigen Substanz. Das heisst, es gibt sowas wie Milchdampf oder was? Ich weiß nicht. Milchdampf und das kondensiert irgendwo? Komm, ich finde es raus. Nee, hör auf. Stefan. Ich finde es raus. Wo kondensiert diese ganze Milch? Kondensmilch oder evaporierte Kondensmilch, auch Dosenmilch oder Büchsenmilch genannt, wird aus Milch durch Reduktion des Wassergehalts hergestellt. Sie wurde ab der Mitte der 90er des 19. Jahrhunderts als Konserve hergestellt und vertrieben, da frische Milch nur kurze Zeit gelagert werden konnte. Das ursprüngliche Herstellungsverfahren beinhaltete die Zuführung von bis zu 45 Prozent Zucker, wie Stefan eben bereits sagte, nach dem eigentlichen Kondensierungsvorgang, wodurch die ja die sehr dickflüssige gezuckerte Kondensmilch entstand. Später gelang die industrielle Herstellung ungezuckerter, ebenfalls haltbarer Kondensmilch, die bis heute vor allem als Zugabe in Filterkaffee genutzt wird. Da möchte ich tatsächlich auch nochmal einen Shoutout dalassen, und zwar hat uns ein HNO-Arzt geschrieben, weil wir haben ja beim letzten Mal spekuliert, was ist Husten eigentlich, wie geht das, welchen Effekt haben Hustenbonbons? Und ich habe ja gesagt, ja, das ist dazu da, damit der Schleim abgehustet werden kann. Und da hat nochmal ein Heim. Ja, meine These, also ich habe mich gefragt. Du hast gesagt, warum ist es nicht in der Lunge? Also wie kommt das Bonbon in der Lunge? Bräuchte man nicht so einen kleinen Mini-Vapor, wenn man es einzieht, irgendwie, dann verstehe ich, dass der Hustenreiz nachlässt, warum man etwas in seinem Mund hat, was dann den Hustenreiz...
Deine Theorie war, warum nicht Lunge, ich habe gesagt, nee, es geht um den Hals und ein HNO-Arzt hat sich gemeldet und hat geschrieben, Florian hat recht.
Und da möchte ich jetzt nochmal wirklich alle...
Nee, nee, kannst du bitte nochmal genau vorlesen?
Da möchte ich jetzt wirklich nochmal alle Hörerinnen und Hörer motivieren, weil das ist genau die Art von Feedback, die wir suchen.
Die Florian sucht.
Genau das, also, ne, vielen, vielen Dank für alle Einsendungen, wir freuen uns immer, wenn da Feedback kommt, aber das ist wirklich so genau für mich, also nur mal als Feedback, des Feedbacks, muss ja auch Feedback, Feedback.
Ich finde, es muss kein Feedback zum Feedback geben.
Ich finde schon, weil man will ja auch richtig Feedback geben und deswegen möchte ich da nochmal sagen, so ungefähr stelle ich es mir vor, dass jemand mit einem Doktortitel uns schreibt und sagt, Florentin hatte Recht.
Also mein Feedback zum Feedback wäre das genau, was ich nicht möchte. Könnt ihr auch für alte Folgen nochmal, wenn ihr einen Doktortitel habt, euch nochmal alle Folgen anhören. Und immer wenn euch auffällt, dass ich Recht habe. So wie Dr. Philipp Hauptmann jedes Mal mir Recht gegeben hat, wenn so physikalische Fragen gingen. So Feedback? Nein, da erinnere ich mich aber anders. Ich erinnere mich daran, dass er gesagt hat, Florentin, ich kenne dich schon lange, aber da hast du mich noch mal überrascht, wie gut du dich auskennst. Never happened. Und ich habe mich dein ganzes Leben getäuscht. Ich gebe dir hier meinen Doktortitel jetzt. Ah, okay. Also so habe ich die Szene in Erinnerung, dass ich einen Doktortitel bekommen habe. So, was hat er geschrieben? Ich kann es dir leider nicht vorschreiben, weil wir es auf Instagram bekommen haben, aber er hat geschrieben, ja, und dann habe ich auch noch zurückgefragt, keine Achtung, Achtung, ja, habe ich noch zurückgefragt, was kann man denn noch machen ohne Hustenbonbon, wenn der Hutzreiz, Hutzreisten, Hutzreisten kommt, der Hutreiz. Ihr kennt das ja alle, wenn man den Reiz hat, sich den Hut so richtig aufzusetzen und auch teilweise über die Ohren zu ziehen. Wenn der Hutreiz kommt, gerade ihr seid beim Zahnarzt und der Hutreiz... Wenn Hutreiz mal wieder kommt. Biobronchale.
Gegen Hutreiz im Alltag.
Aber tatsächlich, ich sehe tatsächlich oft,
so und dann, da kam noch keine Antwort,
aber das nur als Teaser für nächste Woche vielleicht, weil ich finde ja immer gut, was kann der Mensch selber machen. Es gibt ja diese Dinge gegen Gehirnfrost, Zunge an den Gaumen, gegen Nasenbluten, Nackenbluten, sowas. Und da gegen Hustreiz, finde ich, sollten wir mal eine grosse Datenbank machen. Du kannst das Wort nicht sagen. Du kannst das Wort nicht sagen. Nee, vielleicht gab es irgendein Trauma oder so, dass jetzt dieses Wort einfach gesperrt ist oder so verwischt ist im Archiv. Vielleicht muss ich da noch irgendwas aufarbeiten. Aber ich habe ja schon das Gefühl, manche Menschen haben diesen Hutreiz und man fragt sich warum. Also bei Hüten bin ich oft gewillt zu fragen, mache ich natürlich nicht, lasse die Leute machen, was sie wollen, aber es ist so, warum der Hut? Man denkt sich immer, verliere diesen Dreckshut, also verliere das aus deinem Hut. Einfach weg mit dem Hut. Ich habe die Nachricht gefunden, Doktor Matt, ähm, ich will nagen. Matt, ja, der ist kein Matt-Doktor, das ist kein Metzger. M-E-T-T. Ist nicht Doktor Med. Okay. Doktor mit Fleischhauer. Schreibt, lieber, ich lasse das Nachnamen weg, wir wissen nicht, ob er genannt werden will, aber lieber Herr Will, lieber Herr Tietze, bezüglich Ihrer Frage zur Wirkungsweise von Hustenbonbons, tatsächlich sitzt der abzuhustende Schleim meist nicht tief in der Lunge, sondern in den oberen Atemwegen und kann so von einer erhöhten Speichelproduktion erreicht und gelöst werden. Ja? Ja. Und was steht noch da?arte. Zusatzstoffe wie Eukalyptus und Pfefferminz wirken hierbei ebenso schleimlösend. So können sie bei den meisten grippalen Infekten mit Hustenbeschwerden helfen. Sitzt der Schleim in den Bronchien, wie bei einer Lungenentzündung, nützen die Bonbons sie natürlich nichts, wie Stefan bereits sagte. Nein, das steht da nicht.
Hör auf, das ständig überall mit reinzunehmen.
Und es muss mit Inhalationen oder medikamentösen Schleimlösungen gearbeitet werden,
wie Herr Tietze eingangs auch erwähnt.
Liebe Grüße, Doktor.
Und dann hast du noch geschrieben, wunderbar, vielen Dank für die Aufklärung, viel zu froh.
Kann man denn sonst noch etwas tun, um einen Hustenreiz zu unter... Du hast wieder Hustreiz geschrieben.
Jetzt heisst er Hustreiz.
Hustenreiz. Ich kenne es als Hustenreiz, egal. So eine Drücke und man keinen Bomben zu anhat. Nutz schlucken. Du wolltest also praktisch überlegen, ich sitze im Musical...
Kann ich schlucken um meinen Hustreiz zu unter...
Niemand kann der Story, weder den Songs noch der Story folgen, weil ich die ganze Zeit huste.
Weil ich im Rhythmus, im Takt
huste.
Schlucken oder noch besser etwas trinken
hilft natürlich auch, am besten etwas Warmes.
Aber wenn man nun in einer Situation ist,
wo man keine Hilfsmittel zur Hand hat,
kann es tatsächlich schwierig werden,
den Hustenreiz, er hat es auch nochmal
betont, weil du es falsch reist,
zu unterdrücken. Manche empfehlen Atemübungen, wie die Luft gegen den geschlossenen Mund ausatmen. Die Luft gegen den geschlossenen Mund? Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob man ... Wie geht das? Also eigentlich die Back ... In die Wangen atmen. Ah, ich persönlich finde diese Übung jedoch nicht hilfreich. Dann können wir es auch abkürzen. Alles klar. Ja, vielen Dank, Herr Doktor... Mett. Herr Doktor Mett. In diesem Sinne wissen wir jetzt Bescheid, Herr Flotin, ich gebe dir diesen Punkt, du hattest Recht. Niemand muss mehr husten. Aber ich hatte auch nicht unrecht. Nee,, wir hatten beide recht, aber ich hatte mehr recht. Denn die Bakterien spielen sich ja vor allem auch in der Lunge ab und deswegen ist es nicht so, manchmal auch nicht hilfreich, neuntersuchte wie stark eure Lungenentzündung vorgeschritten ist. Ja, also spannend, wir lernen hier viel dazu, es ist cool.
Absolut, ich versuche jedes Mal auch ein bisschen was mitzubringen und wir haben heute was gelernt über das Mittelmeer, Atlantropa und ja, falls ihr Ideen habt, falls ihr viel Geld habt, kann man das vielleicht nochmal umsetzen. Die Idee war natürlich auch, Europa und Afrika näher zusammenzubringen. Ein Projekt, das wir natürlich auch schon seit Jahren verfolgen, was auch wir schon festgestellt haben, nicht so leicht ist, weil es schwierig ist, Brücken zu bauen. Die Idee war dann natürlich, dass man dann auch bei Gibraltar und so, dass man dann Tunnel bauen kann, von Europa nach Afrika, also dann schön Köln-Kapstadt, kannst du dann schön Zug fahren, ICE-Ruhrabteil. Und auch von Italien aus gibt es dann Tunnel runter nach Afrika. Und das war natürlich die Idee, das auch zusammenzubringen. Klar, du sagst es natürlich völlig zu Recht, sind da nicht auch kolonialistische Beweggründe mit dabei? Weil natürlich die afrikanischen Nationen haben da jetzt nicht so viel Mitspracherecht bei dem All. Das sind natürlich alles valide Punkte, die du zu Recht aufwirfst, die gerne diskutiert werden können, aber der Grundgedanke ist natürlich interessant zu sagen, können wir nicht dieses Mittelmeer einfach weg und dann einfach eine grosse Landmasse haben. Ja, das kann man natürlich auch beim Atlantik oder im Pazifik überlegen, ob man nicht einfach brauchen wir, und da müssen wir uns als Menschheit Gedanken machen, brauchen wir Weltmeere? So, und ich glaube, jetzt sind wir an einem Punkt. Klar, heutzutage weiss man mehr und konnte heutzutage berechnen, dass ein solches Projekt den Golfstrom umgeleitet hätte, was Europa in eine sehr starke Kältephase gebracht hätte und den Landbau und die Landwirtschaft mehr oder weniger unmöglich gemacht hätte. Ja, oben, vielleicht an den Punkt, wo wir sagen, es ist vielleicht gar nicht so schlecht, wenn es ein bisschen kälter wäre, weg mit dem Golfstrom, lass uns diesen Staudamm noch mal machen. Und die Erben Sörgels so. Genau. Here we go, unser Great Grandfahrer. Und kommen noch mal und fahren alle mit dem Fahrrad zum Bundestag und wollen dort ihr Projekt vorbringen. Könnte natürlich eine interessante Idee sein. Ja, also vielleicht kramen wir den alten Sörgel noch mal raus. Und dann ist natürlich auch blöd, wenn das Leben von vielen Millionen Menschen an einem Staudamm hängt, weil wenn der mal irgendwie mit einer Atombombe zerstört wird, dann ist halt Schluss, weil dann sind halt diese 500.000 Kilometer dann halt doch wieder unter Wasser. Aber geht das so schnell. Und das ist dann schon ungünstig. Geht das so schnell? Interessante Frage. Ich glaube, das ist schon, wenn dir so 100 Meter Wasserspiegelunterschied. Ja, geht wahrscheinlich schon schnell. Das ist, also klar, du hast wahrscheinlich schon ein paar Stunden, aber das reicht ja nicht, um Millionen Menschen zu evakuieren. Also heutzutage vielleicht keine so gute Idee mehr, aber du hast ja bestimmt eine andere tolle Idee. Wenn du die jetzt so schlecht findest, dann hast du ja bestimmt einen Alternativvorschlag, Stefan. Nee, ich finde es total cool, zum Beispiel zu überlegen, wir schütten alles, was wir nicht mehr mögen. Also ich habe zum Beispiel auch in meinem alten Kinderzimmer noch viel Kram. Und das schütten wir alles auf in der Mitte von dem Atlantik zum Beispiel. Also Müll, ja? Genau. Gerümpel. Gerümpel. Deutschland rümpelt aus. Und dann darauf bauen wir ein Land. Okay, und dadurch steigt ja der Meeresspiegel, oder? Wenn es mehr Land unter Wasser gibt? Ja, dann müssen wir ein bisschen Wasser ins Weltall. Okay, also wie stellst du dir das vor? Wasserbomben? Wie so Wasserbomben, Wasserlosballons. Eine intergalaktische Wasserschlacht schlägst du vor. Nee, so als Spaß versteckter, eigentlich wollen wir nur das Wasser loswerden, aber als so ein so be so wir bewerfen den Mars mit. Oder tauchen wir die Aliens auch so unter im Wasser und so. Der Mars hat das ganze Wasser verloren. Wir haben zu viel Wasser, Meeresspiegel steigt. Stimmt, haben wir das Wasser geklaut vom Mars? Das weiß ich nicht, möchte ich mir auch nicht zu äussern, habe ich Angst, irgendwie eine Wette einzunehmen, die ich nicht mehr zurücknehmen kann. Ihr willst dann noch politisch offen bleiben. Ja, ich möchte nur sagen, wir haben zu viel Wasser, Mars hat zu wenig Wasser, wir bewerfen den Mars mit einer Wasserbombe. Das ist ein No-Brainer. Das ist ein absoluter No-Brainer. Das finde ich nicht so schlecht. Ja, ich mag's, die Idee gefällt mir. Und wir können dann auf unserem Gerümpelhaufen, der besteht aus so alten Steif-Dinos und Gogos, kennst du noch Gogos und all die Geokarten, darauf können wir ein neues Leben anfangen. Eigentlich auch eine schöne Metapher. Auf unseren… Auf Müll, aus Müll entsteht neues Leben. Ja, okay, aber auch aus unserer Kindheit haben wir gelernt. Okay, also seit alten Pokémon-Karten und He-Man-Figuren entsteht neues Leben. Genau, am Ende ist das das Gerüst einer funktionierenden Gesellschaft, ist eine glückliche Kindheit. Keine Jugendarbeitslosigkeit zum Beispiel und so. Alte Relikte der Jugend führen dann dazu, dass wir ein neues Leben. Oh Mann, mal planst du gerade hier in der Bundestagswahl anzutreten? Stefan, ich sehe doch deine güldenen feuchten Augen wieder. Habe ich dich? Huck mal, die Fischereifischscheinphase hat genau eine Woche gedauert. Jetzt der Weg zum Bundestagsabgeordneten. Ich habe noch nicht angefangen zu fischen, weder zu fischen noch zu lernen. Naja, nach Komplimenten schon. Aber ich habe mich gefreut, jetzt schon so ein bisschen zu wissen, was in der Prüfung passiert. Ich habe mich nämlich schon für die Prüfung angemeldet, dies im Dezember. Das ist für die Prüfung angemeldet, ohne irgendwas gemacht zu haben? Also du gehst da völlig blank rein. Nee, genau. Du sagst, was kann ich alles schaffen durch reine Improvisationen. Ich fange jetzt an zu lernen, aber der Prüfungsstabin steht schon, ich habe schon die Prüfungskosten überwiesen, ich bin schon angemeldet für die Prüfung in Kölle. Und jetzt muss ich noch lernen. Theoretische Prüfung, oder muss dann auch was angeln? Die ist sowohl die theoretische als auch die praktische. Da muss was rausziehen. Nein, du musst nichts rausziehen, du musst nur für bestimmte Zwecke bestimmte Angelrouten zusammensetzen können. Mhm. Und man muss Fische erkennen, irgendwie sechs aus... Woran? 50 verschiedene Fische, also musst du einem aussehen, es werden Bilder hochgezeigt, du musst sagen, das ist die Barbenwelssalmling. Und du glaubst wirklich, dass du das durchziehst, bis Dezember hunderte Fische auswendig lernen? Ja, wirklich. Safe, absolut safe, ich verspreche dir das. Wollen wir auch mal wieder was machen, irgendwie ins Kino gehen oder so, weil ich habe manchmal das Gefühl, dass du, ich will nicht sagen, zu viel Zeit hast, aber jetzt irgendwie hundert Fische auswendig lernen. Einfach, also wie gleich können die aussehen, also ich kenne schon, der eine hat rote Punkte, der andere ist kariert, der andere hat Striche, der andere hat Hörner. Auf manchen stehen Zahlen drauf. Auf manchen stehen Zahlen, auf manchen stehen sogar drauf, wie sie heissen. Deswegen heissen die ja auch so. Deswegen heissen die ja auch so, die Drecksidioten da draußen. Also die Tiere wurden ja nach irgendwas benannt. Genau. Von daher stelle ich mir das eigentlich ziemlich einfach vor. Ich bin sehr gespannt, wie das weitergeht und ob Stefan das wirklich schaffen wird. Bleibt auf jeden Fall dran. Es bleibt spannend.
Bleibt in der Leitung. Sorry, wir haben es auf dieser Folge nicht mehr geschafft. Ich habe meine Abiturprüfung aber dabei. Sie liegt jetzt hier im Studio. Die Philosophie GK-Prüfung für Abitur 2013. Können wir nächste Woche, wenn wir es schaffen oder halt woanders? Wir haben ja keine Eile. Wir können sie auch komplett veröffentlichen. Der läuft ja nicht weg, auf gar keinen Fall können wir die Bücher komplett veröffentlichen.
Wir können sie auf, ich würde sagen, stefan15.de ist die Domain, wo wir Stefans komplette Abiturprüfung hochladen können. Da könnt ihr mal vorbeischauen und euch da mal durchklicken. Könnt euch mal durchklicken und die lustigen Zeichnungen, die ich mir gemacht habe, angucken. Wir lesen die noch vor, macht euch da keine Sorgen, wir vergessen das nicht, liegt das hier, wenn wir dazu kommen, wenn wir uns nichts mehr zu erzählen haben.
Richtig, da werde ich es merken, der Punkt, und dann können wir das immer noch aufmachen.
Ansonsten vielen Dank an Thomas für das Intro, vielen Dank, haut rein, macht's gut, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Danke Stefan, dass du mit dabei warst.
Vielen Dank, vielen lieben Dank, mach's gut Florentin, ich würde sagen, komm, wir betreten gemeinsam das Ufo und heben ab.
Komm, ich mach dir die Tür auf.
Nein, nicht dir.
Und der geht schon los.
Wir haben abgedrückt.
It's a worst bird production.